lancement en alsace d'un site de
production d'électricité à partir de
géothermie profonde
le premier ministre était cette semaine
sur place pour son inauguration
voyons en quoi cette expérience
consistaient surtout car il pourrait
être sa capacité réelle à être une
alternative énergétique rentable
reportage
kristin booth de loin on ne distingue un
nuage de fumée
en réalité de la vapeur d'eau c'est la
preuve que le site pilote de géothermie
profonde de soussous forêt produit ses
premiers kilowatts heure jean-jacques
grâce travail depuis cinq ans à ce
projet dont l'étude a démarré il y à 22
ans et 164 très émouvant aujourd'hui de
voir qu on y est arrivés on a réussi à
mener ce projet à bout a prouvé qu'on
peut produire de l'électricité à partir
de la chaleur des roches profondes car
le principe est à la fois simple et
complexe sauce et puis c'est une
véritable plongée au centre de la terre
à 5000 mètres là où la température de
l'eau géothermale dépasse les 200 degrés
cette eau est ramené à la surface grâce
à une pompe une fois l'eau chaude
remonter on lui enlève ses calories
transformée en électricité grâce à une
turbine air générateur qui injecte le
courant dans le réseau une telle
centrale géothermique n'est rentable
qu'un certaines conditions en reprenant
une installation nous ré depuis qu'il
descendrait à 3 kilomètres de profondeur
pour produire avec une eau à 150 degrés
environ 3 mégawatts électriques il nous
faudrait un tarif de l'ordre de 20
centimes d'euros par kilowattheure 20
centimes au lieu de 12 centimes d'euros
prix auquel edf rachète actuellement
l'électricité géothermique le site
pilote de soultz sous forêts est capable
d'alimenter 1200 foyers
c'est peu mais la source d'énergie
inépuisable découvrir paris autrement
cement d'alsace d'un site de production
d'électricité à partir de géothermie
profonde
le premier ministre était cette semaine
sur place pour son inauguration
voyons en quoi cette expérience
consistaient surtout car il pourrait
être sa capacité réelle à être une
alternative énergétique rentable
reportage
christine cros
de loin on ne distingue un nuage de
fumée
en réalité de la vapeur d'eau c'est la
preuve que le site pilote de géothermie
profonde de soultz sous forêts produit
ses premiers kilowatts heure
jean-jacques grâce travail depuis cinq
ans à ce projet dont l'étude a démarré
il y à 22 ans et en température on était
bien actuellement
actuellement 160 très émouvant
aujourd'hui de voir qu on y est arrivés
on a réussi à mener ce projet à bout a
prouvé qu'on peut produire de
l'électricité à partir de la chaleur des
roches profondes car le principe est à
la fois simple et complexe sauce et puis
c'est une véritable plongée au centre de
la terre à 5000 mètres là où la
température de l'eau géothermale dépasse
les 200 degrés
cette eau est ramené à la surface grâce
à une pompe une fois l'eau chaude
remonter on lui enlève ses calories
transformée en électricité grâce à une
turbine air générateur qui injecte le
courant dans le réseau une telle
centrale géothermique n'est rentable
qu'un certaines conditions
reprenant une installation n'aurait
depuis qu'il descendait à 3 kilomètres
de profondeur pour produire avec une eau
à 150 degrés environ 3 mégawatts
électriques il nous faudrait un tarif de
leurs deux vaches centimes d'euros par
kilowattheure 20 centimes au lieu de 12
centimes d'euros au prix auquel edf
rachète actuellement l'électricité
géothermique le site pilote de soultz
sous forêts est capable d'alimenter 1200
foyers
c'est peu mais la source d'énergie
inépuisable découvrir paris